as to the eagles
i i said
yesterday and we've said this before
they view backup quarterback as a top 15
position on the roster so
it's not going to be jalen hurts and
nate sudfeld it's not going to be jalen
hurts and just some guy who's there in
the event that jalen hurts gets injured
it's going to be jalen hurts and someone
else who is capable of starting and the
report came out yesterday they want
competition for hertz because people say
well you just traded the competition no
they want different competition they
want competition that actually embraces
competition carson wentz didn't want to
compete for the job he thought the job
should be given to him that's fine
that's his prerogative that's his
priority whatever
now miles i look at the eagles and and i
wonder do they use the sixth overall
pick
on a quarterback and have a second year
guy and a first year guy or do you try
to find a veteran to come in to help
develop jalen hurts and also to be that
that compliment to younger guy order guy
you know nick foles he could come back
for a third stint with the team i don't
suspect he'll be back with the bears but
uh which which way do you think they
will go or should go
younger guy than hertz or somebody who's
been around the block a few times
i would go younger guy and i and i say
it because i think you want the person
with the higher ceiling if you bring in
somebody like a nick foles like a ryan
fitzpatrick comes to mind just because
of what he was able to do with tua and
the relationship that they seem to have
established i think it sets your ceiling
a lot lower than it probably should be
and what you would want it to be
at the quarterback position but if you
bring in a guy who's a rookie you think
that maybe that guy can eventually turn
into an elite level quarterback and
that's what i think you want you don't
want somebody who's just gonna be
middling somebody who can maybe get you
to the super bowl if you have a really
really really good defense i think you
want the guy who's going to be the guy
and i don't know that jalen hurts can be
that guy i don't know that he's not that
guy either but i think because you just
don't necessarily know what nick sirian
is going to be as a head coach how he's
going to be able to develop quarterbacks
but at the same time you brought him in
there for a reason you've got the number
six overall pick you want to never have
a pick that high again with that
particular head coach might as well roll
the dice see what you can get at
quarterback and see if that guy can turn
into an elite level player because
if you don't have an elite quarterback
it's very very difficult to win a
championship
the one mystery in all of this that we
may never get a full and straight answer
to is why did the eagles use a second
round pick last year on jalen hurts is
it as simple as we need two quarterbacks
we've learned from experience that with
carson you have to have somebody else
available because
he he inevitably gets injured 2017 got
injured against the rams in december
then 2018 the back problem 2019
everything's going well we get into the
playoffs now i don't know that you can
blame carson wentz for getting a
concussion when he had an illegal hit
from davey and clowney of the seahawks
when they were playing the wild card
game but i just i i'd love to know
because it could be that
either they they told carson once they
were gonna do it and he didn't like it
and they did it anyway or they just
didn't properly communicate it to him
but where did the relationship go
sideways and what impact did this
decision
to take jalen hurts have on it and why
at the core at the bottom line why did
they do it did they anticipate there was
going to be a regression with carson
wentz because if they did
they were right
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports